hey remember last week when i said that
that video was the most difficult video
i'd ever done yeah well i was an idiot
thing this one was way harder or dare i
say impossible i wanted this video to
cover all of the remaining batman films
in the last two decades but there were
too many so instead i decided to
dedicate this video to the nolan trilogy
and catwoman while covering the dc
universe films joker and the brand new
the batman movie starring robert
pattinson next week but this week as i
mentioned we're covering one of the most
critically acclaimed superhero trilogies
of all time movies that possess highs
way way higher than anything i covered
last week and it also has catwoman which
is a poison to my eyes ears and mind the
likes of which i won't soon recover from
but hey variety is the spice of life
right so let's quit wasting time and
dive straight into our first review and
the very first time i've ever seen
2004's utter commercial and critical
disaster catwoman
no god please no no
no
no
catwoman one movie into this mammoth of
a video and i already have a headache
let it be known that had this film not
been part of this massive video project
i would have stopped watching at about
the 13 minute mark when this reptile was
talking down to this girl and yes the
dialogue is on the nose and cringe but i
would have stopped not just because of
that but because this film is so damn
boring the setting isn't remotely
interesting and the first four minutes
of the film just tell us about the
history of catwoman with flashing images
the idea that there's only one year of
separation between this monstrosity and
the christopher nolan trilogy is kind of
wild when you think about it i mean it's
kind of like one year before the release
of dragon ball super
you might have had dragon ball evolution
and that is all to say that this
catwoman film did not do well racking up
an impressively bad nine percent on
rotten tomatoes and absolutely tanking
in the box office catwoman stands
proudly as the single biggest critical
and commercial failure i'll be covering
in all of these videos so i hope you're
having fun with my misery this dumpster
fire tells the story and i'm using those
words loosely of selena kyle's catwoman
and that was a lie i told you a lie just
now this isn't selena kyle's story but
that of another catwoman i guess called
patience phillips i think they might
have struggled to get the rights to the
character or something unlike selena
kyle's tale this isn't a story about
liberation or freedom from the shackles
of society's expectations but instead
it's a film that revels in them paired
with that are some of the most bizarre
choices in terms of filmmaking the cg
has aged horrendously and that damn
basketball scene has taken years off of
my lifespan to try to strain together a
coherent thought concerning this film is
an exercise in insanity and i mean that
the story is about a woman who inherits
the ancient egyptian power of the
catwoman dresses in the minimum amount
of clothing as a pg-13 film would allow
and succeeds in overthrowing a corrupt
beauty industry exec all the while
wooing her object of desire mr man over
here
the final battle is really really lame
and let me emphasize just how lemon is
by showing you how the villain dies they
battle she lands some attacks on her
face she looks at her face in a
reflection and oh no i'm not pretty
anymore oops i let go and now i'm
falling to my death
and okay look my biggest issue with this
film isn't that it's entirely vapid and
insulting to the catwoman character it's
actually a little more specific than
that her agency power and freedom are
all derived from her hyper-sexualization
leaving the core character in this film
bereft of any sense of identity to
bolster this point here's a direct quote
from the costume designer of this film
angus strathe he said we wanted a very
reality-based wardrobe to show the
progression from deburr repressed
patience to the sensual awakening of a
sexy warrior goddess
that is a real quote from a real person
that worked on this movie
and if we want to talk about quotes tied
to this film in 2018 john rogers
credited as the third writer in this
film which meant he was probably brought
into the project late in the scripting
process had this to say on twitter
regarding the film quote full disclosure
i was fired off of this movie after
writing the green light draft because i
kept arguing with notes that it'd make
the movie very very bad which i said out
loud at beatings pitov the director had
an eye for action but nobody in power
knew what movie they wanted at one point
i said you do realize the big third act
fight in your summer tent pole is halle
berry dressed like a quebecois stripper
beating the [ __ ] out of a makeup exec in
a pan suit i mean you know you have a
bad movie when it's a burn when someone
describes exactly what the third act of
your film is and i mean he's not wrong
from a comic accuracy point of view even
the wikipedia page of the film felt it
necessary to have this as its first line
catwoman is a 2004 american superhero
film loosely based on the dc comics
character catwoman to the point of it
being in name only and has nothing to do
with the batman franchise this reads
like someone in dc made sure that there
was a disclaimer at the beginning of
this wikipedia entry so yeah yikes and
do you know what the craziest part of
all of this is out of all of the absurd
decisions made in this fever dream of a
feature i learned that halle berry made
14 million dollars playing catwoman here
to put that into perspective toby
maguire was paid 4 million for
spider-man 1 a much better film tom
holland was paid 10 million for
spider-man no way home a much better
film and andrew garfield was paid 1.5
million for both the amazing spider-man
1 and 2 combined which let me remind you
are both infinitely better films than
whatever this was i've no idea what
hollywood was doing back in those days
with their money but damn those are my
thoughts in this garbage fire of a film
this was a painful one out of ten i
would not recommend to anyone and now
it's time for something completely
different it's time for the christopher
nolan trilogy starting where it all
began
batman begins 2005.
there's nothing to fear
itself
i am writing this review of batman
begins mere moments after having just
finished watching the film and i cannot
believe just how much it blew me away
seriously this movie fascinated me
reinvigorated me and brought me to tears
perfectly capturing everything i've
learned to appreciate and love about the
batman mythos over the last month
through the comics exploring how he came
to be what he represents and why he
trudges forward why he struggles and why
when he falls he will always pick
himself right back
up the film itself from what i've
noticed takes inspiration from a number
of brilliant batman comics the first is
perhaps the most obvious with 1987's
batman year one the second being batman
the long halloween released between 1996
and 1997 and finally the third a very
short comic called the man who falls
written by dennis o'neil and illustrated
by dick giordano in 1989 and despite
being just 16 pages in length this one
still managed to say enough to make an
impact on me as a reader having it
quickly become one of my favorite batman
comics to date with its very title
speaking to one of the most impactful
lines in this film the comic itself is a
concentrated retelling of previously
published batman stories and the
similarities to the comic particularly
in certain key moments is quite stark
and thankfully that snappy pacing i
loved in that comic is present in this
film too the introduction is remarkably
quick at establishing the central and
even secondary parts of the story to us
if you recall i complimented the first
sam raimi film for being extremely
efficient with his time delivering
exposition but this film takes it to a
whole new level kicking things off in a
setting we've not associated with bruce
wayne or batman for that matter in these
films up until now no shadows no noir
feel just yet instead shrouded in bright
colors in a warm country as bruce hangs
out in prison while the concept and
indeed some of the imagery from that
comic i like is present in these opening
sequences i will say that there is a
stark difference every time bruce did
something academic or ambitious in that
comic you could replace that with theft
or petty larceny in this film and to be
honest i think that works a whole lot
better it paints our hero as a lost soul
wandering the wilderness of the world in
search of meaning in search of a way to
write the traumas of his life and he
finds just that
what are you seeking
i see
the means to fight injustice
i remembered having conversations with
others about this film and indeed the
third in the trilogy after i mentioned i
really liked the dark knight when i
first saw it and regarding this film in
conversation i always left with the
impression that the scarecrow which we
see later played by killian murphy was
the main antagonist similar to how the
joker is in the second this could not
have been further from the case razal
ghoul is the central antagonist to bruce
wayne and indeed batman in this feature
for one fundamental reason he's the
opposite of batman and by virtue of that
fact the opposing force to batman's
goals in this film let me explain the
film drip feeds us different parts of
bruce's backstory from his falling down
the well his fear of bats manifesting
his young adult life struggling with
revenge his adventures throughout the
world his meeting with roz and indeed
his defection from the league of shadows
once he learns of their goals roz
discovers a young troubled man full of
rage with revenge in his heart bruce
blamed himself for the death of his
parents and when the cops catch up to
the person who killed them they tell
bruce
good news
we got him son this doesn't make him
feel better and throughout his life he
ends up harboring this potent resentment
for both the system and the individual
who killed his parents until his hearing
trial when bruce is a young adult and
perhaps at the lowest point in his life
bruce sees his parents killer's
potential freeing as an injustice and is
prepared to do something about it
despite this person's reforming and has
want to do the right thing now
thankfully someone else steps in to do
what bruce wanted before he ended up
making one of the biggest mistakes of
his life and upon reflecting on what
just transpired bruce is almost thankful
and that's when we get one of the best
quotes in the movie bruce says my
parents deserved justice to rachel she
responds well you're not talking about
justice you're talking about revenge
sometimes they're the same he says and
she responds no they're never the same
bruce justice is about harmony revenge
is about making yourself feel better i
love that line confused and distant
bruce yearns to become the man he needs
to be and if he's to make a difference
in the world which fortunately or
unfortunately leads him right to raza
and his training and speaking of which
something i felt was lacking in the
other films was a greater emphasis on
fight scenes beyond simple punching and
kicking and while there was some variety
in the better films back then i felt
like this was the film where batman
finally got to loosen up a bit and get
down to business whether it be in the
prison yard during his ninja training
under raz beating down the scum of
gotham or even with his car which looks
insanely awesome in this by the way
there's a greater emphasis on movement
and choreography that wasn't as
pronounced in the prior films i noticed
to try and understand the character of
razal ghoul i decided to hop into a
comic from the 70s called tales of the
demon a comic by dennis o'neil again
wherein he began to reshape batman in a
serious brooding story prior to his full
reinvention in the 80s within this tale
i noticed a host of similarities between
the comic and film adaptations of the
character while there's a noticeable
difference in appearance from his hair
to the absence of a bright green cloak i
did identify perhaps the best part of
the character his no-nonsense
no-tolerance black and white approach to
tackling moral dilemmas in a utilitarian
fashion roz represents exactly what
bruce wanted to be when he stood in that
courtroom as a traumatized and angry
young adult someone who was capable of
exacting on a grand scale the revenge he
saw as akin to justice however it's that
coming-of-age change in bruce wayne and
his moral code that stands in direct
contrast with raz and indeed every
criminal in this story raz sees it as a
moral imperative to take out the city of
gotham from the corrupt insides out to
start anew whereas bruce wants to
protect them to save them to help guide
them away from the destruction and
vengeance he sought so dearly to get
once upon a time batman begins is a
story about morality and justice in the
truest sense of the word and it's
brilliant
why do you give a damn alfred it's not
your family
alfred is a brilliant character in this
movie and furthermore i do believe that
in this film in an incredibly efficient
manner managed to capture exactly what i
love about the character of alfred in
lesser hands a character with as few
lines as this one possesses would have
been left feeling meaningless or vapid
to varying degrees however at every
available opportunity alfred felt
everything from competent to wise to
warm in equal measure
i give a damn
because a good man once made me
responsible
for what was most precious to him batman
as a character more so perhaps than any
other superhero out there in this genre
is given an identity based on how human
he feels how flawed he is how flawed
everything around him is and why it's
important to hold on to your humanity no
matter what shrouded in the shadows of a
gothic city surrounded by monsters
lurking around every corner nolan saw it
important to inject as much humanity
into this story as one could tortured as
bruce wayne is he needs to have
something worth fighting for this is why
i appreciated characters like alfred and
indeed the rest of the secondary cast
feeling as human and warm as they did
when given the chance rachel is a
terrific rock in the story for bruce
whenever he wavers offering bruce and us
as an audience a means with which to see
bruce's true self show
lucious fox played by morgan freeman is
as warm as he is intelligent offering up
a plethora of gadgets to bruce wayne
that anchor this story to its more
realistic roots while adding some much
needed variety and indeed humor to the
film there's a dry winning rapport bruce
and he shares that's absolutely
infectious furthermore jim gordon has
remained one of my favorite characters
since reading the year one material at
the beginning of my journey back in
january i loved his fish out of water
perspective as he grapples with the
morality bereft circumstances gotham is
confronting him with on a daily basis
when i saw in this film that his partner
was a corrupt cop called flas i kinda
geeked out and said hey i know that guy
he's a [ __ ] you know i really
enjoyed that gordon got to play more of
a role in this film too by being one of
the few good cops in the city not in the
pocket of a criminal underworld and even
when it comes to characters like falcone
or scarecrow there are efforts to
humanize them where possible and fun
fact did you know that killian murphy
who kills it playing the scarecrow in
this movie by the way grew up in my
hometown like 10 minutes from where i
live right now he went to school with my
cousin and by all accounts was a lovely
quiet boy ireland's most famous people
aside though something i did think was
worth drawing attention to and showing
appreciation for is this plot line with
the scarecrow and how his plan to poison
the water supply of gotham is lifted
almost directly from the 2005 comic
entitled the man who laughs only instead
of joker we had the scarecrow carrying
out the plan but i digress this film
deals in such a balanced and measured
fashion with the themes of doing the
right thing no matter how difficult or
harrowing it might be to war against
your inner demons and manage to come out
the other end as the demon that strikes
fear into the hearts of those that would
dare do wrong to the innocent to grow
from the fearful child that once blamed
himself for everything into the hero
gotham needs to shoulder the
responsibilities and protection of
everyone batman begins out of all the
films i've covered so far is by far in a
way the most faithful to the comics
while delivering a compelling
coming-of-age story exploring the themes
of guilt morality and struggle it's a
beautiful love letter to the story i've
grown to love and appreciate as of late
and furthermore i think this is a movie
that everyone should see once and i'm
going to give it the highest rating so
far with a strong 8.5 out of 10. i
adored this film exceptional from its
snappy opening all the way to an ending
which teases a character and performance
that ended up defining a generation of
fans and it all starts with one of the
most beloved and iconic superhero flicks
of all time
i believe
whatever doesn't kill you simply makes
you
stranger
i am of course talking about 2008's
the dark knight
yeah but first a quick word from our
sponsor thanks so much to alien for
sponsoring this video it's been really
cool to partner with a brand who knows
this platform in and out if you're not
familiar with alien clothing they were
created by fellow youtuber elvis the
alien back in 2017 and their product
line is pretty much perfect for this
channel if you love anime movies games
or pretty much anything science fiction
then you're more than likely going to
love what alien has to offer they have a
huge number of awesome designs carefully
curated from some fantastic artists all
over the world and there's a real sense
of exclusivity to picking up their stuff
as they don't do reprints although
they're constantly being updated with
new designs once they're gone they're
gone and what i really love about their
products is that they're surprisingly
competitively priced given their use of
some of the fabric quality on the market
their items are actually all printed and
shipped from canada where they're a bit
of a hit in the skate shop zoomies so if
you want to get yourself some awesome
limited edition clothing head over to
alienclothing.com and use code not mark
to get 20 off with free shipping on
orders over 100 dollars
the dark knight
for context this is the only film out of
the nolan trilogy that i had seen prior
to making this video however i haven't
seen it in over 10 years and watching it
today it's even better than i remembered
and i thought it was [ __ ] great the
first time too as a video essayist i do
try to make an effort to offer a
different perspective when i review a
story where possible however it's
incredibly difficult to say anything
about this movie that hasn't already
been said numerous times over and over
and so instead of agonizing and focusing
on my saying of something unique or
insightful pertaining to this film i am
going to instead share my personal
experiences with this and if something
unique comes out then great
if you haven't watched this movie yet
and are only heard about it let me tell
you that everything you've heard about
it is either correct or not hyped up
enough across the board each and every
actor is on their a game delivering
career defining performances with the
crown jewel of said performances being
that of the late heath ledger's unhinged
and unsettlingly faithful interpretation
of the joker introduced to us in the
first scene of the film as a series of
unnamed and faceless masked clowns
robbing a bank we learn how meticulous
untrusting and chaotic this individual
can be one thing however that i will say
is that compared to the first film which
had a lot to unpack and stayed massively
faithful to the source material in the
comics this one is noticeably more
simple in terms of moving parts and plot
while still taking aspects from the
comics and contorting them into a
brilliant narrative however that is not
to say that this isn't a faithful
adaptation either while there isn't a
singular source drawn from in particular
for the purposes of this film's plot
plenty of scenes are taken from or take
inspiration from numerous separate
sources
act one if the first film detailed a
comprehensive art and story for bruce
wayne as well as outlined his becoming
of the batman then this is the film that
deals with the ramifications of that
reality it's fascinating and exactly
what razal ghoul was looking to avoid
the complications of in his blanket
reset of gotham in the first place so in
a way i love that this film is a direct
result of bruce's choice in the first
outing having become a symbol for the
city one that strikes fear into the
hearts of the criminal underworld and
hope for the citizens of the city batman
has inspired a series of copycats which
led to some funny and terrifying moments
but more important to the story is the
character of harvey dent gotham's quote
white knight and part of what makes this
film work so well is how much we grow to
love and respect harvey as a character
right from the get-go the first
interaction with him on screen is
intimate with him sharing a bit about
his family's history followed soon after
by one of the most badass moments in the
film when a failed assassination attempt
on his life doesn't spook him but
instead encourages him to assertively
punch the guy's lights out dismantling
his gun before saying if you want to
kill a public servant mr maroney i
recommend you buy american
that's badass remember i hadn't seen
this film in over 10 years and to be
honest i completely forgot about harvey
dent and he turns out to be one of the
best characters in this movie if not one
of the most thematically resonant
you either die a hero or you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
what i love about this short dinner
scene isn't just dent doing what he does
best winning my heart but it's the
expression bruce gives as he listens to
harvey and realizes that he's in fact
one of the only genuinely good people in
gotham that has the will to make what he
envisions a reality spawning the phrase
echoed throughout this film i believe in
harvey dent a quote lifted directly from
a wonderful batman comic called the long
halloween in fact the scene where gordon
harvey and batman gather atop a roof
could also be lifted from that comic too
though i will say that compared to that
comic the character of harry dane does
come across in this film as far more
virtuous and true which is a brilliant
change i think harvey's ultimate
downfall in this film is central to the
themes of this story and moreover
totally elevates this film's supremely
brilliant villain
i'm gonna make this pencil disappear
it's
gone
act two joker is the best part of this
film the performance from heath ledger
is next level and i will definitely be
speaking on that in just a moment but
before i do i'd also like to show my
appreciation firstly for how well
written this interpretation of the
joker's character is and how the
narrative is built everything around him
while other characters in the first film
batman begins were in service of bruce
wayne conveying the weakness and
strengths of the character in his
introductory outing in the dark knight
unlike razal ghoul and scarecrow joker
is central to the plot with everything
revolving around him taking the symbol
batman has created for gotham city to
believe in as a challenge to show batman
and gotham just how crazy the rest of
the world really is when you remove that
thin veil of civilization
i'll show you when the chips are down
these uh these civilized people
they'll eat each other
something i noticed this time in this
film that i hadn't seen before was how
convicted joker was in defending his
person not being a quote freak with
numerous times he looks to batman as a
fellow crazy in the circus which made me
think back to the killing joke comic and
the conversation between batman and
joker in the end however there is
something far more explicit that had me
recalled the killing joke in this
particular film the idea that joker
wants his origin or past to be quote
multiple choice i expressed in my review
of batman 1989 that while i loved
nicholson's performance as the joker i
didn't like his backstory it removed a
lot of the mystique for me and humanized
him a little too much but in numerous
instances in this film joker tells
variations on a story he explains is the
origin of his coming to be but each and
every time the story changes adding an
air of mystery to the character with him
coming across as an ideology more so
than an actual person he's a symbol
we don't have to be afraid of scum like
you yeah you do brian some men aren't
looking for anything logical like money
some men
just want to watch the world burn
and that's what this film explores with
the joker being the catalyst that makes
it possible the characters of harry dent
and bruce wayne are pushed the
respective limits to see if their morals
will stand up to the intense pressure of
the joker's antics we've been slightly
teased with dense composure when taking
the law into his own hands to some
extent though still very dissimilar to
the long halloween's comic but when it
comes to dealing with the joker directly
batman has a very different experience
the good cop bad cop routine
not exactly
joker's interrogation this is the best
scene in the movie it's my favorite
scene in the movie and it was the very
first scene filmed for this movie as
many of you know films follow a
three-act structure but like many great
scenes this too follows the three-act
structure and in effect acts as a
microcosm of the entire film's conflict
and struggle not a battle of brawn or
cunning although there is plenty of both
but instead a battle of ideology in
robert mckee's book entitled story he
speaks on the format of various scenes
with particular emphasis on the more
conversationally driven in them he
claims that the goal of a scene is to
communicate a conflict establish the
players on either side what their values
are followed by an emphatic climax of
words that reveal more about our
characters and this scene with the joker
in batman delivers upon that in spades
the interaction starts off like any good
film would with a bang batman appears
suddenly behind the joker antagonizing
him physically this has been a standard
approach he's taken when dealing with
all criminals to tremendous effect
across the board to leverage his
intimidation when interacting with the
unpredictable but instead joker shrugs
this all off and in the same demeanor he
was chit-chatting with gordon moments
prior continues to minimize batman's
presence until batman reveals that he
truly doesn't understand the joker at
all then why do you want to kill me
from this point on joker has become the
one with the answers as batman assumes
his position on the rhetorical back foot
the joker claiming that batman isn't
like those quote normal people he
wishfully claims to be like don't talk
like one of them you're not
even if you'd like to be
to them you're just a freak
this is a curious choice of words you
might remember that in numerous times in
this film joker has taken specific issue
with those in his company that refer to
him as quote a freak or crazy and this
very aspect of his persona this
perspective speaks to the foundation of
why he finds batman so interesting and
why he ultimately carries out what he
does in the third act of this film he
doesn't see himself as freakish or crazy
in the slightest but instead as someone
that operates in a crazy world as one
ought to citing that there is a thin
line between civilized people and utter
chaos
see i'm not a monster
i'm just ahead of the curve and to that
batman either sees that this is a
pointless conversation or when he has no
argument against either way batman has
lost the rhetorical battle in this
ideological skirmish and has now
resorted once again to physical
altercation and once again this doesn't
work and what's more it's egging the
joker on you're gonna have to play my
little game if you want to save one of
them
this is the moment the ball drops and
batman realizes that not only was he
never in control of the situation but
instead has played right into joker's
hands and for a split second batman's
facade breaks uttering out of concern
and confusion the word them
joker realizes this and instead of
answering his question decides to use
his brand of mental warfare to terrific
success against batman bruce is no
longer in control he's seeing red and
continues to dance to the joker's song
your friend the district attorney or
he's washing
this is an immeasurably fascinating
performance with layers of complexity
delivered by heath ledger in this scene
we have the mind games the anarchy the
twisted personality of the joker shining
through as well as this clear enjoyment
of the beating he's receiving with each
punch feeling more and more validated
when it comes to actors there are
elements to each performance that makes
them unique and one aspect of heats i
was surprised to find came from a quote
courtesy of christian bale himself he
said our first scene was in an
interrogation room together and i saw
that he was a hell of an actor who's
completely committed to it and totally
gets the tone that chris is trying to
create with this as you see in this
movie batman starts beating the joker
and realizes that this is not your
ordinary foe because the more i beat him
the more he enjoys it the more i'm
giving him satisfaction heath was
behaving in a very similar fashion too
he was kinda egging me on i was saying
you know what i really don't need to
actually hit you it's going to look just
as good if i don't and he's going go on
go on go on he was slamming himself
around and there were tiled walls inside
of that set which were cracked and
dented from him hurling himself onto
them his commitment was total these
punches that christian bale that batman
throws at joker were real which i think
makes this quote all the more powerful
and he's right
batman has no leverage in this situation
joker doesn't value what he's normally
able to take advantage of with regular
criminals dangling them from buildings
and such this is a man who doesn't fear
death but in fact yearns for batman to
kill him because then his ideology would
be proven correct in his eyes and
batman's echoing the sentiment alfred
laid at bruce's feet towards the
beginning of this film some men aren't
looking for anything logical like money
they can't be bought bullied reasoned or
negotiated with
some men just want to watch the world
burn and if that line wasn't enough the
scene ends with joker giving batman
everything he wanted meaning that all of
this all of this pageantry was for his
own personal enjoyment and okay well he
almost gave him everything he wanted
leveraging his emotional outburst joker
takes advantage one last time giving the
correct coordinates but switching the
locations of each person ensuring that
whomever batman valued more
would likely die it's an outstandingly
fiendish plan the likes of which i still
think about to this day there are scenes
in cinema that go down in history as
some of the best and this is deservedly
one of them two characters verbally
wrestle with one coming out the top in
emphatic and catastrophic fashion taking
not only the police and batman off guard
in the process but us too as an audience
no
no
no it's all right listen
someone
for me this is the highlight of the film
and the most emphatic manipulation in
the film from the joker which sets up
the final gambit introduce a little
anarchy
the final act itself explores the
downward spiral of harvey dent again
loosely similar to the long halloween
comic itself though it again does have
fundamental differences the final
massive set piece with the two boats is
a powerful one that speaks to the
resolve and unwillingness in people to
kill their fellow men no matter their
bias and in a sequence with virtually no
action at all gotham city proved
themselves to the joker he predicted
wrong he thought that they and everyone
was like him but they were not he is a
freak
he is alone however the state of harvey
now following the collapse of his
worldview is a sobering wake-up call to
bruce that he needs to remain in gotham
as the batman for him to live long
enough to see himself become a villain
to be everything gotham needs him to be
not to be a hero but a silent guardian a
watchful protector gotham's white knight
and harvey dent may have fallen but its
dark knight will always remain to do
what must be done overall the film is
spectacular from start to finish with
some of the best scenes i've ever
witnessed the interrogation scene again
is my favorite with just two people
talking now seeing it through the eyes
of someone that understands these
characters a little better than i
previously had i can say that i loved it
even more harvey dent is virtuous alfred
is brilliant lucius is awesome and the
joker is captured perfectly thanks to
the late great heath ledger and the
wonderful writing team behind this film
this is a trend setting and standard
bearer my final rating for the dark
knight is 9.5 out of 10. next up to cap
this trilogy off 2012's
the dark knight rises i was extremely
excited to see this movie and it didn't
disappoint if i was to describe this
film in one word it would be conclusive
and while it does have its weaker points
like its action i genuinely think that
from a story perspective this was a
perfect end to this trilogy of films i
liked the story is taking almost the
exact opposite approach of the dark
knight where batman was looking for a
way to commit himself to a life with
rachel and to leave the work he believes
in to harvey dent this film however
explores the depression and loss bruce
finds himself in now that he doesn't see
a future as bruce wayne yearning for a
moment of respite where he can assume
his alter ego to pretend and live in a
fantasy where he can despite his health
despite the logical decision being to
take a different approach this leads to
those closest to him that remain like
alfred to step away from him as they
can't watch him march down this path of
self-destruction any longer following
the events of the dark knight bruce is
listless unable to move on crippled and
injured from the years of wear and tear
in his body his interpersonal
relationships withering his social life
non-existent and his business on the
verge of bankrupt a company responsible
for contributing large sums of money
towards the various charities of the
area something his father very much
believed in deeply and because of his
declining mental health because of his
fixation on what was instead of what
could be he hurts those around him
including himself now on the topic of
charity and dwindling wealth the themes
of money greed poverty and revolution
are very much a driving force
particularly with the film's secondary
characters and main villain the
wonderful selena kyle makes her nolan
debut here in this picture and i love
anne hathaway's portrayal of the
character the focus isn't on her sexual
awakening like catwoman 2004 but it's
instead concentrating on her position in
the world and the moral code she has the
perspective she possesses speak a lot to
the themes of inequality in the city of
gotham and the world at large her seeing
bruce wayne is fair game to steal from
as he has the means to support himself
regardless she's a criminal yes but she
is principled the same can be said for
vayne now we don't get to see much of
him outside of the first half of the
film but we do feel his presence while
not being the hulking mindless gross
mess we saw in the late 90s
interpretation of the character if you
could even call it that in this he
proves to us why he's one of batman's
most terrifying villains following films
of the dark knight which had heath
ledger's career defining performance in
the joker a lesser director might have
looked to recapture that same lightning
in a battle by trying to recreate the
magic with a different character or
actor no such choice happens here
thankfully the dark knight rises feels
very much like a labor of love with a
particular fondness for the various
idiosyncrasies that make bane such an
interesting character there is a batman
comic series called nightfall produced
during the early 90s and for the most
part this is the de facto bane story
that put him on the map as one of the
most intimidating and terrifying enemies
of the dark knight all the while
managing to tell a grounded story about
batman particularly his psychology in
relation to banes and is not only widely
praised and acclaimed but for the
purposes of this video it served as the
basis or inspiration for part of this
very movie we're discussing today the
dark knight rises
unfortunately i didn't have time to read
this story what can i say i had a lot to
read and watch and it was way too long
to even attempt i mean there's a reason
i'm covering the dc universe stuff in
another video next week i just didn't
have the time but with that said i did
need to find out who bane was so i asked
aj for help once again hello there he
told me to read vengeance of bane a
significantly shorter story released
also in the early 90s covering the
origins of the character from a
faithfulness standpoint much like the
joker while elements of his origin could
be taken from this comic such as the
dungeon where we see that he's from i
thought what this film nailed perfectly
was the spirit of the character as a
whole you merely adopted the dark
i was born in it
from this point on the movie is all go
go go any setup that was previously
required is now replaced with some of my
favorite scenes across all of these
films alfred's coming to terms with
bruce's more self-destructive tendencies
was heartbreaking bruce's refusal to
leave with miranda to go far away from
gotham spoke to that destructive
inclination he still has and bane's
first encounter with the batman is
something i don't think i will ever
forget the quote peace has cost you your
strength victory has defeated you from
bane again speaks to the issues bruce is
willfully ignoring in lieu of continuing
his work blindly as batman and in the
presence of bane unlike anything else
we've seen say for perhaps the joker in
the prior film nothing fazes him and
what's more is he knows who batman is
unlike the joker there's this strange
effect on bane's voice and to be honest
took a long while for me to get used to
it fully initially it sounded silly but
the more i heard it the more invasive it
sounded i don't know if this was a
conscious choice made by the audio
mixing team but bane's voice always
sounded like it was eerily close to me
like it cut through every scene's
atmosphere the action in this film on
the other hand isn't good at all and
i'll say that here to avoid having to
address it later the way it's shot feels
almost amateur compared to the rest of
the film not helped at all by the
choreography which feels more like a bad
power rangers episode rather than a
summer blockbuster of this caliber
however and this is a big however the
first fight against bane is helped a lot
i think by this very weird action and
i'll explain why batman appears weak and
pathetic against bane who barely tries
there's no pageantry there's no illusion
of intimidation the camera work is
intentionally flaccid with bane's men
watching this unravel before their rise
catwoman included his suit clearly
visible cape soaked weighing him down
this all serves one purpose to make
batman appear pathetic totally
outmatched and unprepared and it works
alfred was right
now it's time to rebuild and once again
we get another great sequence of scenes
as bane brings the city of gotham to its
knees without anyone to stand in his way
and we get bruce wayne a beat man
clinging to life
learning how to walk again forgotten at
the bottom of a dungeon in a well unable
to escape
well that is until he does
rise of the dark knight
there's an important change that happens
with bruce wayne in this sequence batman
now is fighting to live instead of
waiting to die what i love about this
story is that it truly feels like one
long continuous narrative across all
three films the reincorporation of
characters like razal ghoul coupled with
the training he needs to undertake in
order to lift himself from this literal
and metaphorical pit of despair harkens
back to the days of batman begins in
other words this truly feels like a
complete series with a singular
uncompromising vision it's spectacular
however i can't help but feel a powerful
sense of what could have been this film
is a powerful reflection on the past
characters like scarecrow reclaim roles
with new positions of power and they are
massively entertaining having discovered
through my research for this video that
he had planned on performing in this
film also makes me wonder in what
capacity would the joker have been
involved in the final product a
character the likes of which is obsessed
with anarchy and chaos would have been
an ideal candidate for the world like
this and so nostalgically i do look back
with sadness but as soon as i do this
film utilizes nostalgia in a positive
way that too serves the story the
resurgence of quotes like bruce why do
we fall haunting his dreams as he fails
to scale out of this pit to rescue the
people he swore to protect serves to
create a sense of occasion and purpose
the likes of which a single movie cannot
on its own accomplish with the final
climbing attempt out of this pit
possessing a powerful philosophy the
likes of which i wasn't expecting though
it is perfect for this occasion for
months as bruce has agonized in this
dungeon he's heard the tale of a child
that has managed to drag himself out of
the darkness a feat no ordinary child or
adult for that matter could perform a
child forged from suffering and pain who
we learned climbed that wall without the
use of a rope the interesting part of
this film isn't necessarily how weak
bruce appeared or how he ultimately
bails himself back up from that but how
bane thoroughly broke his spirit as well
as his back this film explores what it
means to fight fully with mind body and
spirit and questions what spirit in
combat means and how one could expect to
fight with full spirit if they do not
fear death how can they run faster fight
longer than possible how can they expect
to try harder than someone that is
scared to die which honestly is an
interesting concept but when the
solution to this problem was proposed i
myself got scared you see over christmas
i watched a film called free solo and as
the name suggests it follows one man by
the name of alex honold climbing a cliff
face called el capitan in the yosemite
national park in california without a
rope harness or anything and one thing
this film does a great job of is
granting you a perspective on how one
might feel while undertaking such a
challenge which honestly helped me
immensely in understanding exactly the
impulse and mindset bruce was trying to
achieve here i really like also that
upon his return he announces his
presence to the city not with the bat
signal but with a bright fiery symbol
scorched onto the bridge piercing
through the darkness of the night this
idea of batman as a symbol for the city
of gotham is something i truly
appreciated while watching these films
back to back this symbol plays a role in
every film whether it be him
establishing it in the first one he's
reinforcing that ideal in the dark
knight or right now with him standing by
those same virtues to the bitter end in
the dark knight rises it acts as a
powerful through line with all of these
films that in the moment brought a tear
to my eye the other desperation these
cops must have been feeding their
friends and families terrorized or worse
and now with only hours standing between
them and certain death they stand before
bane's army shaking with fear in their
eyes
seeing batman revitalize their morale
with his presence is exactly what i came
to this movie for and boy does it
deliver
the ending i'm not gonna lie having been
so caught up in the moment of bruce
fighting one-on-one against bane in the
rematch to end all rematches when
miranda stabbed him in the back and
announced that she was the one who
escaped the daughter of razakul i lost
my collective [ __ ] a planned three
movies in the making a plan to destroy
gotham completely finally realizing her
father's mission and i love that joker
or no joker this is a top class film
that is so damn entertaining from start
to finish the switcheroo with the main
villain and her backstory the reveal of
robin who is brilliant in the movie by
the way gordon and batman sharing a
super personal moment together and the
final carrying away of the bomb to a
safe distance there's a wonderful yet
haunting sense of foreboding finality to
this ending and furthermore i don't
think i felt a more sorrowful scene
consisting of just one man's reaction
than i did with alfred's breakdown in
front of the three headstones of the
wayne family apologizing profusely to
tom and martha for not being enough to
save their little boy and i'm not afraid
to admit it this really got it got me
good
i'm not sure what the feelings
surrounding this film's ending are but
for me this was as close to a perfect
ending for this trilogy that i could
imagine i have quite literally no issues
narratively and what's more is that the
surprises it's filled with were not only
previously established but they feed
into the motivations and themes of these
films perfectly i cannot describe to you
the whirlwind of emotions i felt as it
was explained that an autopilot system
had been installed into the back craft
or geez when alfred sat down in that
restaurant a scene established at the
beginning of this film perfectly in line
with the mechanics of what was
established with the clean slate tool
provided to selena the motivation of
batman to finally move on to bigger and
better things in life and of course
alfred finally getting closure for his
perceived failings in raising his dear
friend's only child bruce wayne it's a
powerful ending full of catharsis and i
for one am over the moon that this is
where christian bale's batman was
finally laid to rest at no point did
this film trilogy ease up or rest on its
laurels at no point did it coast or rely
on the brand of batman to carry it forth
onto the global zeitgeist this trilogy
is a work of art produced by a team of
visionaries that understood the
characters on an intimate level a level
i felt that only now having delved into
the comics as deep as i have could fully
appreciate this will not be the last
time i see these films and to anyone out
there who hasn't revisited these films
or has seen them at all please go fix
that as soon as you can this is my
favorite story of the trilogy and of any
batman film i've seen over this long
journey and while the action in this
movie leaves a lot to be desired and its
antagonists weren't as iconic as heath
ledger's joker i am still willing to
give this film a 9.5 out of 10. it's
just that damn good next week i'll be
tackling my final batman video where i
review the dc universe films with batman
and i will finally watch the new batman
movie starring robert pattinson but
until then i've been totally not mark
i'll see you all next weekend
thank you all so much for watching
no that was a big video for you
there it is
[Music]
you